you know i almost don't think there is
an america anymore i mean obviously
that's what i'm fighting
that notion it is incredibly pervasive
and poisonous and difficult to fight
against it but you know
the issue is the media is completely
fractured
the daily beast says that it is an
alt-right conspiracy
this this lively hypothesis they
criticized bill maher and brett
weinstein and heather hein for even
talking about it
and day a month earlier you actually had
the new york new york mag putting out
the the big story but the lively
hypothesis
so it's like if the daily beast and the
new york mag are both prominent
mainstream outlets
and they're both telling us totally
different things that you're a nazi if
you believe it or it may actually be
true
no one has any idea what to actually
believe and and there's no
unified culture i was looking at gallup
polls
we go back to approval ratings to say
eisenhower to jfk
and the divide between democrats and
republicans in approval was like
30 30 to 28 meaning
yeah 65 percent republicans would
approve and then 30
of democrats but it was fairly like you
know everybody was kind of
now it's joe biden it's worse than it's
ever been 87
is the gap donald trump was 76. the
hyper polarization is getting to the
point where
there is not one but two different
americas right now
because of that i don't think that
there's an actual cohesive america it's
split into two
different entities and and right now you
have
you know uh cnn and all these outlets
like i mentioned the daily beast could
tell you it's an alt-right conspiracy
theory
and the washington post can literally
put an article saying it's a
strong hypothesis we must consider so
which one do you pick
which side are you on which which
america do you fall in because you can't
be in both same time
either you're an all-right nazi for
believing it or even washington post is
pushing the idea and so is bill maher
but it's it's not even about a clear
divide it's about
mass confusion and i know q all the
super chats about yuri besmanov
hey we're here how can there be a
functioning america
if no one can agree on any set of facts
and it's almost intentional on the part
of the media
you know there was a great line in
president trump's first inaugural
address
that uh that i kind of hang on to is
that
um through love of country will again
learn to love each other
and i think that the solution to this
and look i'm not saying gonna win not
saying it's gonna prevail i'm saying
this the fight only ends when we stop
fighting it
and that is basically patriotism we've
got to unify again around love of
country
and that's why it's so we have to speak
out so loudly when we see people
disrespecting the symbols of the country
like kneeling at a football game when
they're doing the national anthem etc
etc i mean you're right it's a battle
and it's it's i know i've seen people on
twitter saying oh we've lost the country
it's over but
it's only over when we stop fighting you
know i value the const the u.s
constitution heavily and
but i wonder if i see automation on the
horizon in a way we've never
anticipated and if it's not so much
about the borders of the
united states but if it's about the
constitution and proliferating that
concept globally i mean the
the news organization is already global
they've fractured us our our economy is
global
it's been you know poverty's fractured
so more than it's ever been in this
country
and it seems like it's expanded the
wealth gap is expanding
so what rather than at least the way i'm
trying to go into it is
is like some sort of economic parody
like that's why i love andrew yang
i don't know how you guys feel about his
his you know
monthly fee or whatever ubi universal
basic income doesn't work
well neither do what is what we're doing
so maybe it doesn't work less than what
we're doing now texas is working great
florida's working great but what do you
mean
it's new york that's in the i can't you
know we caught in the crapper
in the craft california the government's
making is fiscally solvent is that what
you mean working great
yeah jobs are exploding people are happy
kids are going to school but there's a
lot of poverty through at least
throughout
there's way more way more homeless in
california than anywhere else in the
developed world poverty is a
relationship i think
the definition of developed world i'll
clarify that but poverty is sort of a
relative thing somebody who's relatively
poor today would be essentially a king
50 years ago and so in terms of what
they've got but it's not
it's not the poverty per se it's the
ability to get out of it
and if you set your mind to it what
obstacles you have just amount and
again you look at a state like florida
or texas or some of these other
successful red states
but you look at new york or you look at
california yeah it's a dumpster
and you have to start thinking about why
so we're thinking about equality of
opportunity giving them the ability to
get out of the poverty state
that's where ubi i like but not this
doesn't mean you just need access to
opportunity
you just need to be able to do that and
a government that's out of your way
and and basically a community for you to
grow up and where people
basically support each other there's
there's trust and it's easy to
to to work through that society it's
very difficult in a place where
basically neighbors all hate each other
there's a meme going around that said
only crazy people believe government
should solve the problems that
government caused
and and and when we look at the larger
problems i mean when we look at what
we're dealing with
it has the direct blueprints of our
government selling out to the special
interests
in a way that of course is not
capitalistic that is not free enterprise
in a way that is collusion that they're
that they're colluding
in a way that they're doing it secretly
in a way that they're conspiring that's
screwing everyone else over and if you
think the government could could take
more money from its citizenry and
redistribute it
fairly accurately uh you got you got to
be you got another thing coming
you know we wouldn't need ubi if we
didn't have these corrupt
worker visa programs and unlimited
illegal immigration there would be no
need for it
you would be able to get a decent job
you would be able to to start a family
at
you know in your mid-twenties and be
able to get a house all those things
would be feasible
it's this has been taken away from us by
our government that is serving
these international globalist
corporations that's what the
the problem is they're simultaneously
uh well as you mentioned with it's not
just illegal immigration it's
immigration in general
that means you're adding to the labor
market in very very large numbers
but business isn't developing that fast
so
if if one person's and outsourcing like
i mentioned the coding thing
the digital world is going to rapidly
change this in a lot of in a lot of
crazy ways uh automation is gonna change
this
and that means we're you combine that
with with with immigration
you the labor market's gonna explode and
there's gonna be no jobs for people i've
often like fancifully
thought that we're evolving out of a
monetary society in general that money
is kind of like a transition
period and we're almost posts not post
scarcity but post
money maybe you know they say currency i
make the metaphor that like electricity
is current currency and that may be the
future of currency is
your access to electricity that you can
build and make the things you need to
succeed in life you don't really need
them we don't have replicators man
that's not true but i don't know if it
feels like we're on the cusp of
something like that
and we're trying to solve this problem
with money but
the problem is the money the problem is
you've got people who propose ubi
well that would basically mean people in
cities get free money and don't have to
work and people live in the countryside
have to still farm and do a lot of back
breaking work so like free
work free electricity maybe if you could
give people free electricity
but how would you give them free
electricity there's no such thing as
free yeah somebody has to do the labor
to produce it no matter what that labor
is
and that means the cost is always there
be it i'll give you this bottle of water
in exchange for your labor you paid the
cost for give someone the opportunity to
create their own electricity
how riding a bike every day i don't know
so who's going to make the bike
who's going to make the general
specialists you know and then you got to
pay them
so it's not free maybe you don't maybe
you don't need money to pay people you
just need electricity
no i don't know man i'm just trying to
trying to solve this in a different way
this is something we see very often on
the left is the idea that money is a
thing
that money is the driver when money is
just an idea that tr
allows transactions it doesn't matter if
you're giving someone a bottle of
shampoo or a sandwich
that's what you are paying i could pay
you in seashells if you valued seashells
i could pay you in old shoes if you
valued shoes
there will always be a cost reason that
producing something because things need
other things to exist if you want to
make a bike you need rubber you need
metal you mean you need someone to make
the gears you need the labor of putting
all together and you can't just have
people do it for free
unless you have a gun slavery well
there's nothing free
and the government has to take it from
someone else and then give it to someone
else
there's there's nothing that the
government does that is free well you
get you you know what money is though
it's just a temporary store or value so
let's say
i had a bicycle and it broke and you
said well i'll fix your bicycle for you
and i said well i'll tell you what
that sounds good i have a cow give you a
gallon of milk but i'll give you a
gallon of milk
a week from now but you know just to
keep track of things i'm gonna give you
like a little note that says this note
is good for one gallon milk
a week from now i'll hand it to you and
then you give it to him to pay for some
cabbages
that's all money is it's just a
reflection of a value that we already
it's a placeholder yeah and they've
they've kind of decommodified it so it's
like this is a general placeholder for
any
i like it works and it's a fantastic
evolutionary process that we've come
across currency
that it was invented and that we use it
but this is what i said
i need to be the way i think that's why
i said during the lockdown that only
after the last supermarket has closed
the last dairy farm has dumped all of
their milk into the ground and the last
farm
has you know shoved all the crops back
underground
will these leftists realize you can't
eat money
it's an it's a plan an old saying about
only after the last river is polluted
and the last forest destroyed it's
native americans saying i believe
and all these leftists got really mad at
me for saying it
because i mean it's a very simple bit of
logic the money isn't the food
ubi doesn't give you anything what is
that value in that check it's
nothing it's basically saying someone
did work
somewhere and you should have access to
it sure
but does that mean they're gonna be
people who are willing to work in
exchange
for nothing or for less it creates a
massive inequality
you'll have people who live in big
cities and you already do who don't work
and get access to the resources produced
by farmers who do work and live out in
the middle of nowhere
the general idea from any of these
leftists is that you shouldn't be
allowed to own what you make
that's it the means of production are
controlled by the people and what you
produce belongs to everyone
so you start seeing these really messed
up scenarios with the system
in north korea for instance if there's a
family a community i'm sorry it's not a
family there's a community that has
access to cows now the cows belong to
everyone to the people
so what happens is one day the cow dies
and all the people in that community
look at it and say
we should eat this you can't because it
belongs to everyone
so what happens is the guards will come
and take the meat and it gets tribute
distributed across the entire nation
which is ridiculous
really hard to do and results in some
people getting spoiled meat
so sometimes when the cow is dying
they'll have no choice
but to secretly steal indeed it and you
get sent to the gulag for that
the problem is if you want to create a
society where everyone's equal and
everyone gets access no matter where you
are and what you do
you create a wildly inefficient system
that can't transport resources properly
and it ends up with people doing a ton
of work and some people doing literally
no work
you have people in north korea this is
amazing i love this their job is to be a
skateboarder
it sounds like magic to most
skateboarders in this you know in the
united states they have skateparks in
north korea
where there's their kids who skate and
their job is you must be good at
skateboarding
so that we can produce good
skateboarders and make good videos
because other people in the world want
to buy
access to videos they want to buy the
content they want to buy the product
and we want to be competitive so they
don't do any work other than just going
skating
and that sounds like paradise to a lot
of people until you realize that once
you develop that system
they're not going to make you the
skateboarder they're going to make you
go mine
sulfur and there's going to be 10
skateboarders and your teeth are going
to fall out of your mouth
that's what you get when you get these
systems it doesn't work
and we've seen it over and over again
but you get a large enough population of
dumb people
to scream and demand it they get their
fingers into the institutions
and then you are left with a bunch of
spineless
fat wealthy or well-off americans and i
don't mean the general wealth i mean of
the world
and so long as they are fed they will
not stand up and they will not defend
their values
and that that's what allows these
lunatics to take over and destroy
everything do you support
unemployment insurance social security
yes um
so like government handouts basically
the government supplies you with
something
you pay the you pay for those things so
that's not a government handout i don't
you don't suppose so especially not
social security it's a scam but that's
not the same thing as ubi because the
social security is basically
it's worse than you paying for it it
actually was stolen from you
and you could have put that money into
almost any other investment and come out
like a millionaire with wealth you could
give to your kids instead the government
steals it and gives you a pittance
of a percentage of interest so um
unemployment insurance is actually
it's it's not it's funded by people
paying it like
we all have to pay it because we're
again nothing's free you pay social
security and if you were able to invest
that money even independently
you would get way more money than the
little bit that the government gives
back to you that you paid into
and then anyway they're in the united
states they're taking that money and
literally
investing it into the stock market and
it's screwing people over on on levels
that are just absolutely crazy to the
point where we're at right now
where there's even some people saying
that there might not be enough money
for other people's social security even
though if they paid for it they've been
saying that since the 90s and they've
been
and you we've had past presidents raid
social security for use in other areas
but
let me clarify i support the ideas yeah
me too
we all pitch in and then when someone
falls on hard times we pick them up so
jack murphy was talking about this on
one of his shows recently
about the us constitution being written
for an agrarian society in the 1700s and
it reflects that a lot of the things in
the constitution like what
you know uh right to carry a weapon you
can't do it in new york city but you can
do it when you're what's that got to do
philadelphia and new york were not
agrarian when the constitution was
signed but the entire
society was that they built the
constitution around more or less i mean
it was like past stories
you know it was absolutely not there was
some industry but it was certainly and
you can still walk with a firearm around
dallas or houston
people in 1776 had private warships
they could literally lay siege to new
york if they chose to do it
but you can't have warships you could
also have slaves in 1780 because it made
a lot of sense you can't and we haven't
been to the constitution
we've changed it the point is the right
to bear witness to do with agrarian okay
well let's talk about the slavery clause
then you'll find slaves were fined 780
they're not fine anymore we changed
so we're maybe we should rewrite a bill
of rights for the internet
age where we're we we give ourselves
these a
unalienable opportunities access to
electricity
access to running water access to a
place who provides those things
well we would provide it to ourselves
through taxes whatever you want to call
it taxes
something like that someone has to do
that labor as opposed to ubi it would be
something more like you have
who is going to build the system and
maintain it to give you water
know i actually went to a country where
they intended to do that
they tried to do it and ensure equity
and i saw equity with my own eyes
it was a tower of skulls five stories
high
the killing fields of cambodia the
aftermath of the khmer rouge and po pot
trying to execute exactly this
vision so i i know it sounds good and
sounds appealing equity of what
equity of opportunity life equity of
outcome no it's
but opportunity you're talking about
outcomes i'm talking about opportunities
no you're saying about outcomes
you've got to have gas you gotta have
internet you have to have healthy as a
basic opportunity
that's not an opportunity if you don't
have clean water you're done
but that's not an opportunity it is an
opportunity that's already kind of
our local communities have passed laws
to ensure that thank god
and if they hadn't you wouldn't know but
who but who drinks tap water anyway
we're going to costco buying it from
them
well a lot of people drink tap water and
they filter it and et cetera et cetera
okay so they didn't have electricity in
this society and you couldn't get it
you'd be done
you you'd what do you think here's
here's your problem you think that we
have electricity because of the
government
and we don't we have a centralized
electric grid that we we have
electricity because of the ingenuity of
in entrepreneurship of the american
people yeah we don't need
to do this stuff i just want i like the
opportunities how do you guarantee
someone water electricity if they're
homeless
you know you can provide the opportunity
you can't make them take what's that
well how do you give someone the
opportunity to drink water and have
electricity if they're homeless
create water stations electrical
chargers who's gonna build the water
stations who's gonna build the
electrical
stations meet them me and a bunch of no
no no no no come on you have no there's
no there's
hire
that's meaningless it's utopian when you
get into po that's why you're in
politics you say tax money that's the
answer if you want to do
social programs you get the people to
pay taxes and come together
i want to take from you ian so i can
give to matt
that's basically what you're saying i
would like to produce so we can all have
to
you you mentioned that slavery should be
wrong it's a wrong and it should be
illegal
yet we we still have a system first of
all the 13th amendment as kanye west
pointed out still allows for slavery
with prisons and we saw kamala harris
take advantage of that in a very
disgusting way having people fight
wildfires at their own
risking their lives that's what that's
that's the same thing about it
but taxation is a particular problem not
in and of itself
it's the fact that you have a corrupt
government that
takes from people to spend on nonsense
overseas
now the concept of taxation i'm not one
of these lazy fair capitalists who
thinks that taxation is theft
i think the manipulation of our current
political system is for the most part
theft because they're taking from us
from our labor at a time when we're most
desperate
and giving it to pakistan for gen for
gender studies programs
they're giving to sri lanka for speed
boats and regardless of whether you
agree with it or not they're giving it
to other
countries they're putting in afghanistan
iraq they're putting it in israel
they're putting it in yemen they're
putting it in sudan
for military purposes because we support
or oppose certain regimes
they're spending money in in syria why
we are losing we are bleeding jobs our
economy's in the gutter people are
desperate for
any amount of money to pay their bills
now that's theft when you've got someone
who's on their knees begging please i
just need to drink
water i need a building i can live in
and they say well we're going to take
some of your money
and give it to syria and yemen that's
theft it's brutal
it is i agree i don't like paying taxes
and not knowing where they go not having
control over it but if we could focus
energy and money or whatever into a
program together that's transparent
that'd be cool yeah i think the problem
is always corruption
the left tries to claim that what's
going on right now is the is the
intended consequence of capitalism
that's not true
and when people point to what happens in
these communist countries
these things are also deviations from
what the ideological
ideology dictates perhaps it's because
it's impossible to have a communist
system as the ideology dictates and
perhaps given a long enough period of
time maybe it's a short period of time
maybe it's longer
capitalism devolves into a corrupt crony
system where people manipulate
the system for personal gain and strip
your resources away using power
power force yeah power corrupts absolute
power corrupts absolutely you would be
way better off
instead of asking and demanding the
government to do something
then you doing it with private
enterprise voluntarily with other people
around you that say hey
there's this project let's fund it let's
do it let's let's do something
entrepreneurial
that will actually help people and
incentivize people to do the right thing
you have a way better chance of getting
success that way than beating at the
doors
of big government that's infiltrated by
big tech by the corporate globalist
monopolies
and saying hey take more money from
these people what are they going to do
with that money they're going to take it
for themselves and they're going to give
you
a half ass program that doesn't work
that doesn't do anything you look at all
the basic social services in the united
states so
so many of them are corrupt so many of
them provide
inadequate services to say the least
and for them to get more money more
power to to be incentivized on their
corruption on their middle man
gangster-like activity
is just pointless you're better off
doing it on your own what
i question i agree with you to a point
because i think if we started like a
private quasi-private public enterprise
that was able to raise money to build
electricity and water and housing
for people it's some if it was a profit
then we would start to make money and
then when
do we prevent ourselves from becoming
corrupted we need like a government
oversight we need some sort of
protection so that we or whoever we
pass the company to doesn't you know
it's just uh
corruption happens and given a long
enough period of time
you'll start to see corruption so i
agree i think we need i i'm in favor of
a mixed economy with with certain
regulations
but then what happens when the system
just becomes more and more corrupt and
nobody wants to actually deal with the
tough questions and the hard problems
one of the issues i think we have as a
country is that we're extremely wealthy
all of us every single one and so we're
you know to put it simply fat and happy
we got our food we got our mcdonald's we
got our chicken wings we got our super
bowl
now the ratings are down mind you but
people were just sitting around saying
why
bother it's so easy to just sit look it
it's so easy to be a middle manager at a
cracker factory
and not have to think about any of this
stuff and just go home and eat your ice
cream and watch a football game
it's easy no why ask the hard questions
why put yourself at risk
you've got it made now things are
getting harder we saw in 2008 with
destruction of people's lives
this sparked a populist uprising it was
fractured by identity politics
we're still in that mess people started
losing
and life started becoming harder now
with covet as things become harder and
harder i think we're on the verge of
people just basically having their heads
explode
because now they're actually becoming
desperate now they're actually going to
lose their homes
now they don't actually have jobs now
they're actually going hungry now you're
going to see angry people
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you